J'avais l'habitude de m'asseoir dans mon bureau au SCC et d'
écouter des conversations téléphoniques
ici même dans la ville d'Ottawa simplement parce que
je m'ennuyais et que je n'avais rien de mieux à
faire et que tout continue avec maman sur
le moteur qui reste stable Eddie ouais mais ce
n'était pas le cas.  un semi-aride acide immédiat ou
Allen ne se plaindra pas de
la situation par le reste de la plupart
avant alors qu'on nous disait publiquement
aux terroristes ennemis des communistes et
à la pratique que ce n'était pas c'était tous nos
amis et partenaires commerciaux, ces
agences ont le pouvoir qui  vont au-
delà même de leurs propres gouvernements respectifs
en 1943, au plus fort de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale, les États-Unis et la Grande-
Bretagne ont signé un accord s'engageant à
coopérer mutuellement dans le domaine de la
surveillance électronique. Ensemble, ils
ont réussi à déchiffrer le code Enigma
utilisé pour crypter les transmissions allemandes.
déchiffrer les communications de l'ennemi
signifiait connaître sa stratégie signifiait gagner
la guerre
en résolvant l'énigme les Alliés ont raccourci
la guerre de deux ans en 1946 le
pacte entre les deux pays a été rebaptisé Royaume-Uni États-Unis et
élargi pour incorporer trois nouveaux
partenaires Canada Australie et Nouvelle-
Zélande l'identité du nouveau  l'ennemi est
évident le bloc communiste forme donc une
sainte alliance d'espionnage est scellée entre
les cinq États aujourd'hui la guerre froide est
terminée
mais cette alliance secrète existe toujours
ensemble les cinq pays gèrent un
réseau secret géant capable d'écouter
la planète entière bienvenue sur le
plus grande opération d'espionnage au monde
bienvenue sur le réseau Echelon
Duncan Campbell est un
journaliste d'investigation britannique spécialisé dans
les questions de renseignement en 1998 la
communauté européenne a chargé Campbell d'écrire
un rapport sur Echelon le résultat a été
des capacités d'interception mm dont
la publication a provoqué de nombreuses discussions en
1988 Campbell avait  a déjà révélé l'
existence d'un réseau de
surveillance électronique ses révélations ont suscité
peu d'intérêt du grand public Campbell
connaît le réseau mieux que
quiconque où il va
scandale suit Campbell est le
spécialiste du réseau échelonné oui
il y a un nom de code donné par les
États-Unis et d'autres pays  dans l'
alliance d'écoute de certaines des
stations qui interceptent les communications
des satellites commerciaux, ils gèrent un
système de surveillance mondial totalement intégré dans lequel les stations d'
un pays collecteront des informations et
les transmettront automatiquement aux
renseignements américains, qui le voudra, c'est pendant de nombreuses
années le réseau de communications électroniques
mais  ils circulent était plus grand qu'Internet
lui-même et même aujourd'hui, il est
très très grand, collectant des millions de
messages chaque heure, les analysant et
transmettant les résultats à travers le monde. les
signaux terrestres des
satellites de télécommunication peuvent être
interceptés à travers de vastes zones. Le
système Echelon consiste à déployer
d'immenses paraboles.  des antennes dans ces
zones afin d'intercepter illégalement
les signaux véhiculant nos
télécommunications le plus souvent d'énormes
balles de golf connues sous le nom de dômes à rayons cachent l'
orientation des antennes
après tout on ne dit pas à quelqu'un qu'on
espionne
la répartition géographique des cinq
pays partenaires rend possible
surveillance des télécommunications
dans le monde entier les informations recueillies sont
traitées par cinq
agences nationales de surveillance électronique
Nicky Hager est un journaliste d'investigation
néo-zélandais en 1996, il a
publié Secret Power une vaste
enquête sur la partie néo-zélandaise du
réseau échelonné, il a même réussi à entrer dans
un  station d'écoute
quand j'ai été secrètement à la façon dont
Hawkeye était stationné en Nouvelle-Zélande et que j'ai
regardé à travers les fenêtres là où les
opérations se souviennent, j'ai vu la pièce
où elle est décomposée en
appels téléphoniques ici et en réparations là et en e-mails
là et passons en revue  ces
ordinateurs puissants qui recherchent tous
les sujets qui les intéressent et
en fait il n'y a personne là-bas,
tout le système peut fonctionner tout seul.
Nous avons emmené Duncan Campbell dans un endroit en
Cornouailles dans le sud-ouest de l'Angleterre, près de
la lande, lors de la station de neige, afin d'
expérimenter avec un chillon.
les techniques d'interception de style,
il semble que la place
du changement pendant la situation soit maintenant
pire qu'elle ne l'était avant
Javier de téléphone mph et la contraction
avec le jeu, donc il n'y a pas d'ensemble d'étapes de la
part des Américains sur la symétrie, c'est
bébé un Shalom  ce système très simple,
petit scanner de batterie, nous pouvons écouter
une communication à la fois, tout ce que nous faisons est de
rechercher les satellites, vous pouvez
voir comment l'antenne que nous
utilisons pointe de la même manière
vers un satellite proche vers certains  parmi
ceux qui sont derrière moi, ce sont des données, c'est
la fin d'un appel,
c'est un fax, c'est
peut-être un défi, nous ne savions pas comment
procéder, le pays des animaux dit que j'ai
une vie maintenant, c'est censé être un
téléphone privé.  appelez, nous ne savons pas où
elle pourrait être n'importe où dans l'
hémisphère occidental, elle pourrait être au Chili, elle
pourrait être en Pologne ou elle pourrait être dans un
navire dans l'océan et ce système
le capte parce qu'il n'y avait pas
de meilleure vie privée que les Britanniques.  et
d'autres services de renseignement américains exploitent
les signaux qui transitent par satellite de manière
complètement non privée et qui d'autre vous
pouvez vous amuser en tant qu'amateur en faisant cela,
ils investissent des milliards de francs, des centaines
de millions de livres sterling dans l'espionnage en
exploitant les insécurités des
satellites, je ne peux pas  fais ça pour toi
assez pour être quelqu'un je ne peux pas me
soutenir nous suivons les principales
différences entre nos expériences et
nos échelons sont le nombre de communications
interceptées le fait que nous ne pouvons pas
cibler certaines conversations et
surtout les supercalculateurs qui
composent le  réseau et qui sont
capables de passer au crible des millions de
communications interceptées,
je m'appelle des USA à l'Australie
au Royaume-Uni, ces ordinateurs sont tous reliés
entre eux, ils s'appellent des dictionnaires,
on peut saisir par exemple le
numéro de téléphone ou les coordonnées bancaires d'une
personne à contacter.  espionnés et les
ordinateurs se mettent au travail, ils fonctionnent un peu
comme un moteur de recherche Internet, mais
au lieu de scanner les sites Web, ils scannent
nos télécommunications. Mike Frost était un
agent de renseignement canadien, il a travaillé
pendant 18 ans au CST, l'
agence canadienne de surveillance électronique, en tant
qu'ancien haut gradé.  officier, il
connaît parfaitement les capacités techniques du réseau,
si ces particuliers
tenaient une conversation et utilisaient des
mots clés qui sont dans le
dictionnaire de l'ordinateur, alors cet individu
deviendrait une cible oui, il suffit de
taper sur l'ordinateur et vous êtes maintenant
à la retraite
chaque pays partenaire produit une liste de
thèmes ou de mots-clés qui peuvent être modifiés
ou mis à jour à volonté et les ordinateurs se mettent
au travail, ils sont capables d'analyser le
contenu des e-mails et de les classer en
conséquence, c'est ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence sémantique
mais pour aller plus loin, ils  peut utiliser
la reconnaissance vocale, donc si un individu
a une voix distinctive, il est relativement
simple aujourd'hui d'introduire un échantillon de cette
voix dans l'ordinateur et de dire à l'
ordinateur que je veux uniquement des médicaments
contenant le mot prononcé par cet
individu et l'ordinateur le fera
indépendamment du  quel mode de
communication cet individu utilise
étant lui-même propriétaire d'un téléphone fixe ou ou
autre d'après la presse américaine
ce système dont le nom de code est voice
cast a été prêté par la NSA aux
autorités colombiennes traquant Pablo
Escobar le célèbre trafiquant de drogue
Escobar a été abattu par la sécurité
en décembre 1993,
Wayne Madsen était un agent de
l'agence de sécurité nationale américaine.
Il travaille maintenant pour l'EPI. Voir une organisation de défense des libertés civiles. La
NSA est la est le chef,
c'est de loin la plus grande, elle est plus grande
que toutes les autres agences de renseignement électromagnétique
réunies, c'est essentiellement
la  contrôle du réseau pour tous ces
différents systèmes comme un obus et
d'autres systèmes qui capturent ces signaux
d'intérêt, donc c'est le c'est le c'est
le grand-père de tous les
systèmes de renseignement électromagnétique qui composent l'alliance Royaume-Uni-
USA la NSA a un
pouvoir phénoménal Fort Meade  son siège est
situé entre Baltimore et Washington
DC ici la NSA reçoit tous les
messages interceptés par échelon à travers
le globe et ne redistribue que ce qu'elle
choisit aux quatre autres agences
des 38 000 personnes employées par la NSA
20 000 notre base ici
la NSA recrute plus de mathématiciens
que toute autre organisation au monde,
son budget annuel de trois virgule six
milliards de dollars la rend plus grande que le
FBI et la CIA réunis.
James Bamford n'est pas un
journaliste d'investigation américain qui a écrit un
texte faisant autorité sur la NSA, le
palais des puzzles en 1983. Bamford  a découvert l'
histoire étonnante de la NSA et a même pu
entrer à Fort Meade. La NSA a été créée en
1952 par un ordre très secret attribué par le
président Truman. C'était une société par opposition à
la CIA qui avait été créée quelques années
plus tôt. La CIA a été créée publiquement, mais
lorsque la NSA a été créée  créée, elle n'était connue de
pratiquement personne et pendant environ les
10 premières années de la NSA, l'existence même de la
NSA a été gardée secrète. La NSA est imprégnée
de la culture du secret. Ses employés
doivent s'adresser aux chirurgiens et aux dentistes
recommandés par l'agence pour un traitement,
juste au cas où.  ils parlent de l'esthétique de notre père
ils sont encouragés à se marier en interne
et à avoir le moins de contacts possible avec le
monde extérieur la NSA est
également connue sous de nombreux autres noms il y
a un énorme incinérateur
un énorme destructeur de documents afin que des
millions de livres de documents chaque  L'
année dernière, ils sont devenus pape et ils
en ont fait des boîtes à pizza et ils les ont vendues. L'
année dernière, ils ont gagné
environ soixante mille dollars en vendant des
boîtes à pizza qui étaient autrefois des
documents top-secrets et pourtant, Esterline ne
pouvait pas accéder à toutes les télécommunications,
ce n'est qu'un des  de nombreuses méthodes de
surveillance électronique utilisées par les
puissances britanniques et américaines pour écouter cela. L'
un de mes emplois au CST consistait à me rendre dans nos
ambassades canadiennes à l'étranger et à
évaluer techniquement l'environnement pour la
collecte secrète des
émissions électroniques de cette ambassade et l'un de
mes emplois  était de mettre en place l'opération et de la
préparer,
l'équipement doit être amené généralement
sous le couvert de la valise diplomatique et installé
dans la pièce et allumé et vous êtes en
affaires,
cela peut être aussi simple qu'une très petite
antenne, une très petite  un récepteur et un
enregistreur installés quelque part dans un placard
et quelqu'un s'y rend une fois tous les deux ou
trois jours et change la bande ou
change le disque, cela pourrait être aussi petit que
cela ou cela pourrait être aussi complexe que
tout le dernier étage d'une ambassade
composé  de 1415 personnes là-bas
par exemple à Paris un environnement radio très très complexe
Tokyo et d'autres villes
très très complexes protégées par
l'immunité diplomatique les ambassades sont des
endroits idéaux pour installer des dispositifs d'interception
afin de capter les communications
à l'intérieur d'un pays donné vous voyez
ici vous voyez cette structure  en
haut, cela ressemble à un
tipi indien avec des petits paratonnerres au
sommet, je les regarde construire, je les regarde le
construire et je sais exactement ce qu'il
y a là-dedans, tout le dernier étage en dessous,
où vous ne voyez aucune fenêtre,
serait la zone.  là où les gens travaillent au moment
où nous parlons, la structure à l'extrémité
du bâtiment en bas est relativement
nouvelle et vous pouvez voir que, cachée derrière la
vitre, il y a une sorte de boîte rectangulaire avec
des paratonnerres sur le dessus et
à l'intérieur de cette boîte soit en ce moment, soit  ils y
installeront très prochainement des antennes d'écoute,
c'est l'une des méthodes qu'ils
utilisent couramment pour dissimuler leurs
antennes. Ils ont une opération massive
en cours là-dedans, vous pouvez simplement dire par
la taille de cette structure qui est énorme
qui écoutent-ils tout le monde
qui est  transmettant dans cette zone,
tout le monde nous écoute probablement vous et
moi en ce moment, bien sûr, bien sûr, bien sûr, c'est
un événement de fête, bien sûr, c'est
absolument le bureau du premier ministre numéro un,
monsieur, ainsi qu'un certain nombre d'
autres ambassades étrangères dans cette zone, les
antennes là-dedans auraient un  Une
vue claire de ces structures dans ces
bâtiments, les
signaux circulant via des câbles sous-marins
peuvent également être interceptés en 1971 aux États-Unis.  les
bandes de flétan sous-marines les communications
envoyées le long d'un câble militaire soviétique les
plongeurs avaient placé une serviette directement sur
le câble lui-même les signaux micro-ondes
qui transportent nos télécommunications
entre les villes voyagent en lignes droites
entre les antennes l'espace généralement de trente
à cinquante kilomètres l'un de l'autre peuvent
être captés vers le  À la fin des
années 1960, les Américains ont réalisé que la majeure partie
de l'énergie de ces liaisons micro-ondes
dépassait la station cible et allait
dans l'espace et que si l'on pouvait placer un
satellite d'écoute dans la bonne
position dans l'espace, on pourrait entendre toutes
ces communications entre les villes
données.  le succès des
interceptions par satellite les Américains ont développé
d'autres vaisseaux spatiaux capables de cibler
à la demande nos téléavertisseurs
et données informatiques de nos téléphones portables leurs noms de code sont
du mercure en trompette du mercure avancé leurs
antennes se déploient comme de vastes parapluies
atteignant jusqu'à 100 mètres de diamètre
chacune coûte 1 milliard de dollars  L'Amérique
est le seul pays au monde à
posséder de telles capacités de surveillance électronique,
même ses partenaires n'ont qu'un
accès partiel à
trop de pouvoir, ce qui conduit souvent à des
abus de pouvoir.
Le Royaume-Uni. Les États-Unis ne font pas exception à
cette règle.
Un agent Fulmer prend le relais.  le
fil de discussion raconte mon travail que l'
établissement de sécurité patient de 87 à
93 impliquait la transmission de messages et
la réception de données dans le
centre de communication, ils ciblent nos organisations
comme la Croix-Rouge, Greenpeace, d'autres
organisations, encore une fois,
des groupes environnementaux très pacifiques, des choses qui, aux
yeux de personne, ne sont d'aucune sorte  d'une menace
mais hier, ils les ont ciblés, ils ont toujours
voulu se tenir au courant de ce qu'ils
faisaient, qui ils allaient voir, Amnesty
International a joué un rôle important dans l'inclusion de
ceux qu'ils défendaient et ont essayé de
libérer la princesse décédée alors qu'elle la faisait
quelque chose contre les mines terrestres,
des messages constants où elle va, qui
elle voit, comment ce groupe
essaie de former ce qu'ils attendent pour
accomplir la Reine lors de chacune de ses visites
ou le Pape, où il prévoit de voir
qui il va voir, qui va
le voir depuis  au début des années 80, lorsque mes
sources étaient là-bas, la plupart de leurs
renseignements n'étaient pas dirigés contre des ennemis,
ni même contre l'Union soviétique, mais
contre tous les pays voisins
du Pacifique Sud, ils étaient contre le Japon,
ce n'était pas parce que nous étions la Nouvelle-
Zélande que nous avions besoin d'espionner.  sur le Japon, les
États-Unis nous ont demandé par la
National Security Agency de faire partie d'un
système de cinq nations espionnant toutes les
ambassades japonaises dans le monde.
Ainsi, même si publiquement on nous a dit que
les terroristes étaient des ennemis des communistes et que leur
pratique n'était pas, c'était le cas.  tous nos
amis et partenaires commerciaux la
loi américaine interdit à leurs services secrets d'
espionner leurs propres citoyens c'est une
règle non écrite de l'espionnage dans le monde entier en
1983 un scandale a éclaté révélant certaines
pratiques légèrement peu orthodoxes
ou comment contourner les règles
dans un partenariat de cinq pays  il
aurait été très illégal pour le
GCHQ britannique d'écouter les
communications de deux des
ministres de Margaret Thatcher qui, selon elle,
n'étaient peut-être pas vraiment à sa cour, alors
nous l'avons fait, nous sommes allés à Londres et nous avons fait
ce travail pour le GCHQ, nous avons
réussi  en entendant les
communications de ces deux ministres
et nous venons de transmettre ces bandes audio
au GCHQ et ce qu'ils en ont fait,
nous n'en avons aucune idée, jamais bien le
gouvernement ne s'y soumettra, mais ce
genre de chose se produit depuis des
années et des années et  des années et cela
continue au moment où je parle,
mais l'Alliance UK USA est allée encore
plus loin, certaines entreprises seraient
les cibles du réseau Echelon.
William Jefferson Clinton jure solennellement
que j'exercerai fidèlement la
fonction de président des États-Unis.
que j'exécuterai fidèlement la
fonction de président des États-Unis,
alors aidez-moi, Dieu,
en 1993, William Jefferson Clinton est devenu
président des États-Unis, son
objectif principal était de relancer l'
économie américaine. Le communisme était mort au
début des années 90. L'Amérique devait trouver  les nouveaux
objectifs l'un des plus importants
est devenu gagner la guerre économique dans laquelle les
ennemis d'aujourd'hui sont parfois les
amis d'hier les amis ont travaillé
pour l'Agence canadienne de renseignement le
CSE qui était éphémère et directement
Azon avec la NSA J'ai lu un
message direct qui redéfinissait la guerre en
termes économiques  et avec ces nouvelles informations, cette nouvelle
définition, ils ont ciblé de nouveaux ennemis
sous cette définition, tout à coup, il y
avait Airbus et les accords potentiels qu'ils
menaient, qui ils vendaient,
à quel type de prix, quelles étaient les
gammes de produits, c'était tout compris
et c'était "  Il n'y avait pas de restriction uniquement sur Airbus, cela
incluait un marchand d'armes français et les ventes du
GATT étaient ciblées. Il y avait de très
nombreux messages sur le GATT. L'Organisation mondiale du commerce
de nombreux messages sur l'
Organisation mondiale du commerce. La
NSA ne fait aucun rapport de manière officielle
à Boeing ou aux grandes sociétés américaines.
à la Central Intelligence
Agency qui traite les informations pour
l'ensemble du gouvernement américain, lorsque ces
informations sont commerciales, elles sont transmises au
ministère du Commerce où il y a une
section spéciale de la CIA qui perçoit
que les informations peuvent être utilisées pour guider une
entreprise américaine sur la meilleure façon de gagner
le contrat les informations seraient tellement
filtrées que l'entreprise ne
saurait vraiment qu'elles proviennent même de la NSA cette
émanation de la CIA est directement liée
à une agence interministérielle l'
Advocacy Center qui est également hébergée
au ministère du Commerce surnommée la
guerre l'Advocacy  Le centre rassemble des
informations provenant de tous les autres
départements américains ainsi que des
services secrets. Ces informations sont
reprises par les entreprises afin de les aider
dans leur stratégie d'exportation. Son site Internet
précise le message.
C'est le temple du capitalisme. L'Etat est
là pour faire prospérer les entreprises.  que cette
devise particulière soit gravée dans le marbre
montre seulement à quel point elle est devenue démodée
mais bien sûr cette version des faits
ne convient pas à tout le monde James Woolsey
Directeur de la CIA de 1993 à 1995 et maintenant
avocat à Washington DC explique pourquoi les
services secrets  espionner des entreprises étrangères
si nos amis d'Europe continentale
arrêtaient de corrompre leurs efforts pour obtenir
des contrats dans le tiers monde qu'ils
devraient essayer d'obtenir sur la base de leurs mérites, nous
n'aurions vraiment aucune raison de collecter des
renseignements secrets auprès de nous. Je regarde cette
déclaration avec une jaunisse ionisée  Je
souris, c'est des conneries oui, ils ne
ciblaient pas juste pour voir qui soudoyait qui,
je veux dire, oui, c'était là-dedans, mais l'
impulsion principale vient des technologies, des
potentiels de vente, ce genre de choses, un
accord particulier montre toute l'ampleur de
l'hypocrisie du  Version américaine des
événements de 1994 Le Brésil a lancé quatre
appels d'offres pour le projet SIV A.M. dont le but
était d'assurer une couverture radar complète de l'
Amazonie. Un accord stratégiquement important d'
une valeur de 1,4 milliard de dollars. L'
américain Raytheon s'est retrouvé en
concurrence avec le français Thomson-CSF
qui était confiant.  de remporter le
contrat, mais en février 1995, la
presse américaine a publié des articles vantant le
succès de la CIA au Brésil dans la lutte contre
les tentatives de corruption de hauts fonctionnaires
du groupe français. Le réseau Echelon
leur a probablement permis d'écouter
de telles conversations,
accusées de tenter de corrompre les responsables
des entreprises françaises.  L'offre a été rejetée et
Raytheon a remporté le contrat jusqu'à présent, tout va bien,
M.  La thèse de Woolsey tient mais quelques
mois plus tard la presse brésilienne affirmait
que Theon avait également été corrompu Les
responsables brésiliens la roue tourne
en boucle en discréditant un
concurrent européen les services de renseignement
aident une entreprise américaine à décrocher un nouveau
contrat d'une valeur d'un virgule quatre milliards de
dollars  aux affaires américaines et comme cerise
sur le gâteau l'entreprise en question
n'est autre qu'une de celles qui ont construit
le réseau échelonné
Bill Clinton a raison de remercier ses
services de renseignement ils le méritent
et ce budget énorme est justifié et a
contribué à porter un grand coup  lors d'un
cartel de la drogue colombien, vous avez découvert des pots-de-vin qui
auraient escroqué
des milliards de dollars aux entreprises américaines. Votre travail a
sauvé des vies et favorisé
la prospérité de l'Amérique. Je suis ici aujourd'hui
avant tout pour vous remercier, vous et vos familles,
pour le travail et les sacrifices que vous avez
consentis.  la sécurité des
États-Unis d'Amérique, je ne crois pas que le
Congrès fasse un bon travail de surveillance,
par exemple du côté de la Chambre, le
président de la commission du renseignement de la Chambre
est un ancien
officier des services clandestins de la CIA, il s'appelle Porter
Goss, il est membre du Congrès de  En Floride,
comment peut-on supposer que quelqu'un qui
a travaillé dans ce type d'
environnement pour la CIA va
exercer une surveillance appropriée sur ce que
font les agences de renseignement,
y compris la NSA. Au Canada,
il n'y a aucune surveillance gouvernementale sur l'
établissement de sécurité des communications.  du
tout,
c'est l'une des choses que je
demande depuis plusieurs années
maintenant. Je crois qu'ils devraient avoir une
surveillance appropriée et rendre compte à notre propre
gouvernement, c'est censé être une
agence canadienne, cela ne semble pas être
en place.  en fait, ce n'est pas en
place,
la seule connaissance que j'ai de leurs
réponses à qui que ce soit, c'est simplement la NSA
et strictement la NSA, ils sont les
seuls à prendre leurs réponses. Je
pense que les gens sont fondamentalement un peu
indifférents à ce sujet.  ils sont en quelque sorte
endormis, ils diront que je n'ai rien
à cacher, pourquoi suis-je inquiet, pourquoi devrais-je m'en
inquiéter, avec ce genre d'
attitude, cette personne peut se réveiller un
matin et découvrir qu'il est trop tard pour le faire.
tout ce qu'ils pensaient être le
cas
Je ne fais rien de mal peut être un jour
illégal mais alors il est trop tard pour faire quoi que ce soit
et pourtant Chillon est un
atout majeur en termes diplomatiques, militaires et
technologiques pour les cinq
partenaires en tant que cible principale de  les
opérations du réseau l'europe a décidé
qu'il était temps d'agir
en 1998 le Parlement européen a été
sensibilisé à la question grâce à un rapport de
Steve Wright qui a été bientôt suivi par
le rapport Campbell le rapport traitait
de la question de
l'espionnage commercial tel que pratiqué par les États-Unis
des questions sur les réseaux d'interception ont été
déposées au Parlement européen
selon un proverbe américain
pour étouffer une affaire il suffit de
créer une commission d'enquête
les Européens ont fait siens ce proverbe
en juillet 2000 les députés euro ont voté
la création d'un
Commission temporaire chargée d'enquêter sur le
système Agilent, elle n'a eu aucun pouvoir d'agir le
8 mai 2001. Les membres de la Commission se sont
envolés pour Washington. Leur programme
comprenait une réunion avec le directeur de
la NSA, équivalente à la CIA, et une
visite à l'Advocacy Center, mais  à la
dernière minute, toutes ces réunions ont été
annulées le voyage a été écourté et
vidé de son sens la Commission
est rentrée chez elle les mains vides
Carlos quello un eurodéputé portugais
a présidé la Commission Echelon, les
affaires de fait ne peuvent pas disparaître le fait qu'ils ont
annulé les réunions à la toute dernière minute
qui était prévu depuis
longtemps ne sert malheureusement qu'à
souligner que je me
méfiais des différentes
enquêtes parlementaires ou des procès intentés par
des citoyens concernés en Allemagne, en France et ailleurs,
n'ont aucune chance d'arriver à quelque chose que
tout le monde laisse tomber sur tout le monde afin que
personne ne puisse dénoncer son voisin  J'estime
approximativement qu'environ 50
pays dans le monde disposent d'une certaine forme de
renseignement électromagnétique important dans le cadre
de leurs systèmes militaires et de
renseignement. Le plus grand des
pays accusateurs, plus
la Chine et la Russie, la France, l'Allemagne et
Israël, mais des systèmes d'écoute électronique
pour les militaires.  ou à des fins civiles sont
vendues à un nombre bien plus grand de pays d'
Asie du Sud et d'Amérique du Sud, etc. L'
Inde et le Pakistan utilisent chacun le
renseignement électromagnétique dans leurs conflits, etc.
en ce qui
concerne l'espionnage commercial,
les pratiques des
services anglophones sont  loin d'être
unique PR Mile a été chef du
renseignement français la DGSE de juin 1981 à
décembre 1982
DARPA long cours vôtre Rabbitohs c'est
au début de 1982 que nous avons réalisé le
rôle important que le renseignement pouvait
jouer pour les entreprises plus profondes que le colorant
a créé le département du commerce et de la
technologie  logique du renseignement hé j'ai
acheté une leçon même un divorce amer
qui était le début d'un tout nouveau
processus cqc cela impliquait d'abord le
conseil d'administration un accord en cours de conclusion
option entre l'entreprise et la DGSE
lui prendre un membre dont j'étais moi-même
le chef  pour l'ensemble de la première
possibilité de particules de Hong Kong,
j'ai rencontré les patrons de chaque grande
entreprise Frank pour leur demander de quoi ils
avaient besoin en termes d'informations dont nous
bénéficiions à partir de ce moment-là, notre mission
était de développer un système de
collecte de renseignements qui  pourrait être utilisé sur le
modèle de la manière que les entreprises avaient
indiquée pour que tout le monde s'écrie instantanément
un dollar il parlera qu'en 1982 la
société française docile était en concurrence avec
des sociétés américaines et russes pour un
contrat en Inde c'est là que la DGSE est
intervenue.  je me
suis trompé sur les pansements certains de nos
agents avaient réussi à infiltrer
certaines organisations militaires blessées
susceptibles d'être une source d'
information utile sur cette question pas maintenant l'homme sur
le terrain a pu vous obtenir en premier
les propositions de nos deux concurrents
le plus drôle c'est  que nous avons pu
communiquer l'information à Daesil ou
à leur négociateur anglais, vous avez terminé au
moment où il montait dans l'avion pour
l'Inde, il a pu négocier un accord
qui a compromis les deux autres et nous avons obtenu que
l'organe des entrepreneurs soit un coffre-fort  mori
la communauté du renseignement est un
microcosme qui a sa propre guilde de presse professionnelle
duskier est rédacteur en chef du live
audience annual les espions doivent lire
je vous enverrai plus économique super
suprême ou l'espionnage commercial n'était pas qu'un
gadget pour prendre un peu
d'avance  le jeu et c'est absolument
impératif parce que nous vivons dans des sociétés
de plus en plus riches
qui ont besoin de plus de copains et dans lesquelles il est
absolument vital que si les grandes
industries nos exportations obsèdent
Explorer II donc les services de renseignement
qui ont été des soldats à l'arrière  tous
les hommes politiques au pouvoir sont appelés
à aider les entreprises qui sont
la pierre angulaire de la prospérité d'un pays.
C'est la même histoire dans tous les
pays du monde, personne n'a de
limites quant à la mesure dans laquelle ils
utiliseront l'espionnage des communications comme  un
moyen de renseignement informationnel et
finalement de pouvoir
Eve Body a été chef du
contre-espionnage français la DST de 1982 à
1985 il 14 ans il nous faut un
ressortissant européen c'est pareil que le
sabot nucléaire la balance ne s'établit jamais par
le bas mais toujours par le haut
donc  nous devons avoir la capacité d'
intercepter les Américains de la même manière
qu'ils ont les perles pour intercepter nos
communications, alors seulement ils nous prendront
sérieusement en discuter, nous pourrons alors parler et
parvenir à une sorte d'accord, vous verrez,
mais tant que nous  n'ont pas une
capacité égale à la leur, la seule
chose qui peut arriver les fera se
moquer de vous
afin de mettre en place un système d'assurance européen
la condition préalable est que tous
les pays soient du même côté pour que les
grandes puissances européennes soient dans  une
position ambiguë La Grande-Bretagne et
l'Allemagne ont toutes deux des bases américaines sur leur
territoire et elles ne sont pas seules. Il
existe un autre cercle de pays au-delà du
cercle restreint des membres du Royaume-Uni et des États-Unis qui
ont participé au réseau. Ces
alliés de l'ombre possèdent parfois de grandes
antennes paraboliques Ashlock et collaborent avec les
Américains.  agences
qu'ils rejoignent dans les réseaux et
offrent un échange plus limité de
matériel intercepté. Il existe une liste d'une
dizaine de pays allant de la
Norvège à la Corée du Sud qui sont censés
avoir signé de tels accords. Nous
savons maintenant qu'il y a deux ou trois
stations danoises qui jouent  En plus des fonctions de type,
celles-ci sont substantielles, elles sont
clairement liées aux Américains, les
services de renseignement américains pourraient
ainsi tisser leur toile partout dans le monde
pour contrer tout système européen - Ilan putatif.
Heureusement, l'avantage pour les États-Unis n'est pas
nécessairement de pouvoir écouter clandestinement
les informations.  monde entier mais plutôt d'en faire
le pays défendeur tout en les incitant à
ne jamais tenter de développer leur
propre système autrement dit pour leur
collecte de renseignement ou savoir s'ils
seraient toujours dépendants des USA la
grange en est une douzaine ou la seule ressource des
Midlands  aujourd'hui, un pouvoir qui ne
possède pas de canaux autonomes de
collecte d'informations ne convient pas
vraiment en disant que je pourrais vous donner
des informations, que je pourrais vous proposer un système,
vous rendez l'autre pays terriblement
dépendant de moi et parce que plus tard, quatre-vingt-dix pour
cent du temps, vous pourriez  donnez au
pays hôte les informations dont il a
besoin, mais les 10% restants du temps,
vous serez en mesure de manipuler cet accès
aux informations importantes qu'ils
pourraient présenter par-dessus, tout était en avril, quel
jeune honnête et manipulateur vous savez
évidemment quand ils ont entendu parler d'informations
ils ne transmettent que les informations qu'ils
souhaitent divulguer ils fournissent des informations
qui corroborent leur analyse et
correspondent à leurs intérêts et le reste va
dans la déchiqueteuse et tire
la guerre de l'information a commencé
le contrôle de l'information à travers le monde
est la nouvelle arme qui fournit le
pouvoir suprême grâce à  Grâce à leur
réseau mondial de collecte de renseignements, les États-Unis
peuvent fournir à d'autres pays des
bulletins réguliers concernant leur sécurité. En
particulier, ces pays seraient
naturellement encouragés à travailler en
collaboration encore plus étroite avec les États-Unis, de la
même manière que la supériorité nucléaire leur assurait un
statut de leader pendant la guerre froide.
l'information sera la clé
du pouvoir à l'ère de l'information
car toujours le renseignement compte
rien n'est simple dans la course à l'
information stratégique des accords sont conclus et
des alliances pour les services secrets travaillent
ensemble et échangent des informations sur
certaines affaires
nous sommes à la fois alliés et adversaires moyens
de votre  nouveau DD besoin notre cas il nous fallait
pouvoir accéder à certains médicaments
venant des pays du Pacte de Varsovie tu
as supplié les Vasavi ou de
groupes terroristes ce connard de l'est désagréable
donc il était évident que nous avions parfois
besoin de l'aide de la NSA do Lesley
Stahl Zeleny donc personnellement  Je me souviens avoir
demandé aux Britanniques, donc je demandais toujours
aux Britanniques certaines informations
qu'ils nous donneraient sans aucun
problème. Aux 20 volontaires, un
problème.
Le 11 septembre 2001, les
attentats suicides contre le World
Trade Center et le Pentagone font plus de 3 000
morts.
la lutte contre le terrorisme est l'un des
nombreux exemples de services de renseignement
travaillant en étroite collaboration, mais cette
collaboration étroite ne
garantit pas le succès. la collecte de renseignements
n'est pas une science précise, c'est un mythe et
une erreur de penser que la NSA et ses
agences sœurs peuvent accepter de
tout intercepter.  les communications
ils ne peuvent pas certains ne valent pas la peine d'être collectés
certains sont trop difficiles à collecter par
rapport à l'intérêt en théorie ils
pourraient avoir une méthode pour collecter
tout ce qu'ils veulent en pratique comme
tout le monde ils ont un budget et bien
vous ne pouvez pas écouter  tout ce que vous prenez,
les terroristes, par exemple, les terroristes
communiquent très peu par voie électronique
si l'on veut pénétrer dans une
opération terroriste et découvrir quand ils vont
commettre un acte terroriste, cela ne se fera presque
certainement qu'avec
des espions et donc je pense que pendant longtemps,
à l'avenir, les
officiers et agents de renseignement joueront un rôle important
dans le domaine du renseignement humain. L'
électronique est importante et utile pour
protéger la sécurité française et américaine,
mais elle ne fera certainement pas tout le
travail. De nombreuses raisons sont avancées pour
expliquer les échecs des services secrets.
comme l'augmentation constante du
volume d'
utilisation des chiffrements et
des transmissions par câble à fibre optique dans les télécommunications internationales, qui
confronte les agences de surveillance électronique
à de sérieuses difficultés,
nageant dans un flux instable d'
informations, elles n'ont peut-être pas toujours les
moyens d'exploiter toutes
les sources
Le problème que ces agences doivent
subir est que nous n'entendons parler que de
leurs échecs, jamais de leurs
succès, dont les détails doivent
nécessairement rester secrets et que toute
conjecture ne doit pas occulter le fait
que nous ne savons rien des
services secrets ou peut-être seulement ce qu'ils  sont
prêts à nous laisser découvrir face à
leur pouvoir supposé leurs échecs
semblent être des énigmes inexplicables la
guerre de l'information n'en est qu'à ses débuts